ich habe hunger
deshalb gehe ich ins restaurant deshalb
gehe ich ins restaurant
weshalb koche ich etwas deshalb koche
ich etwas
deshalb bestelle ich eine große pizza
ich habe
wurst ich habe durst
deshalb trinke ich ein glas wasser
deshalb
ich ein glas wasser
deshalb bestelle ich ein großes bier
deshalb bestelle ich mir etwas zum
trinken deshalb bestelle ich mir etwas
zum trinken
ist das ein staubsauger
[Musik]
nein das ist kein staubsauger
das ist ein lautsprecher
das ist ein lautsprecher hast du kinder
hast du kinder
nein ich habe keine kinder
nein ich habe keine kinder ja ich habe
einen sohn
ja ich habe einen sohn
[Musik]
hast du ein auto
nein ich habe kein auto
ja ich habe ein auto
ich habe ein auto hast du hunger hast du
hunger
nein ich habe keinen hunger
ja ich habe hunger
bist du verheiratet bist du verheiratet
nein ich bin nicht verheiratet
nein ich bin ledig
ja ich bin verheiratet
kannst du schwimmen kann
du schwimmen nein ich kann nicht
schwimmen
nein ich kann nicht schwimmen
[Musik]
ja ich kann gut schwimmen
kannst du gut
aachen
kochen
nein ich kann nicht gut kochen
nein ich kann nicht gut kochen ja ich
kann sehr gut kochen
ja ich kann sehr gut kochen wie fühlst
du dich wie
du dich
ich fühle mich nicht gut
mir geht es nicht gut
ich fühle mich gut
mir geht es gut mir geht es gut
wie schmeckt dir das essen
es schmeckt mir sehr gut
es schmeckt
nicht
es schmeckt mir nicht
was liest du was
siehst du
ich lese ein buch
ich lese die nachrichten
ich lese eine e mail
was isst du gern was isst du gern
ich esse gern teigwaren
ich esse gern kartoffeln
ich esse gern reis
[Musik]
wie ist das wetter wie ist das wetter
es regnet es regnet es schneit es
schneit
[Musik]
die sonne scheint die sonne scheint es
ist bewölkt
es ist bewölkt
es windet
es ist heiß
es ist kalt
du darfst hier nicht
von
du darfst hier nicht rauchen
sie dürfen
nichtrauchen
sie dürfen hier nicht rauchen
ihr dürft hier nicht rauchen
sie dürfen hier nicht passieren
sie dürfen hier nicht park ihren
ich will fernsehen ich will fernsehen
nein du darfst jetzt nicht fernsehen
nein du darfst jetzt nicht fernsehen du
musst zuerst deine hausaufgaben machen
du musst zuerst deine hausaufgaben
machen
ich will cola trinken
nein du darfst keine cola trinken
cola ist ungesund
du musst dein gemüse essen
ich will dich küssen
ich will
küssen nein du darfst mich jetzt nicht
küssen
nein du darfst mich jetzt nicht küssen
du musst das
essen kochen
du musst das abendessen kochen
du musst die wohnung aufräumen
du musst das geschirr abwaschen
du musst das wc putzen
du musst
wc putzen du musst die wäsche waschen du
musst die wäsche
schon
du musst die kleiderbügeln du musst die
kleiderbügel
zu welchem thema sollen wir neue videos
machen schreiben die kommentare wir
lesen alle kommentare zu welchem thema
sollen wir neue videos machen schreiben
die kommentare wir lesen alle kommentare